[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven spoiler video as most of you know
by now the game of Thrones Season seven
plot leaked online all the way back in
October at first nearly everyone was
skeptical about the validity of these
leaks but as time went on and more
reports and photos continued to come out
it appeared that the leak was nearly
100% accurate there are a few false
leaks floating around the internet but
if you have heard the original one that
was posted on reddit by a way for the
lads then you pretty much know
everything that is going to happen this
season but there is one thing that was
an indie original outline that I want to
discuss with you today
obviously these are major spoilers so if
you do not want to hear them I would
recommend clicking off this video now
but before we get into the spoilers I'm
going to give a little bit of a
backstory first shall we begin
it's no secret that one of jon snow's
biggest objectives this season is to go
down at Dragonstone in mind for some
dragonglass that way he can make weapons
to use against the army of the dead
because as we all know dragonglass is
one of the few weapons that can kill the
others and this dates back thousands of
years ago way before the children of the
forest were forced to shack up in the
three-eyed Ravens cave the children of
the forest actually used to give
dragonglass weapons to the Nights Watch
during the Age of Heroes but over time
as the children of the forest started to
die off it was kind of forgotten about
and the Nights Watch started to lose
focus of who the true enemy was well
thanks to Samwell Tarly this ancient
method of killing White Walkers has been
rediscovered dragonglass was found at
the fist of the first men and Sam ended
up using one of those daggers to kill a
white Walker now this did happen a
little bit differently in the books but
Lord Commander Mormont used to think
about the dragonglass that Sam had which
was actually Jon Snow's dagger Lord
Commander Mormont knew that every man on
the wall needed this obsidian but they
had no idea where to get it but Sam knew
that the children of the forest used
obsidian so he knew they would know
where to find it now we all know Stannis
actually told Sam that dragonglass was
on Dragonstone but Sam wasn't exactly
sure where to fire
on Dragonstone but in the book Stannis
actually told Sam exactly where it was
he told Sam that it was under the
mountain but for some reason they
changed it in the show I guess they just
did that to him could have something big
to discover while he was at the Citadel
so when we fast forward a few years
later Sam is now at the Citadel and he
finds the book that has a map of
Dragonstone that shows exactly where the
location of the dragonglass is Sam tells
Jon were to find it now Jon is on
Dragonstone hoping Daenerys will allow
him to mine for it because he too wants
to arm everyone in the north especially
the Nights Watch as we saw in the last
episode Daenerys said she would allow
Jon to mine for this dragonglass that he
so desperately wanted she even agreed to
supply him with men to help him if he
needed in the preview trailer for
episode 4 we can see Jon Snow Daenerys
and missandei walking into what looks
like a cave as Jon leads the group with
a torch now this is where the spoilers
are actually going to come into play and
some of you might not think this is a
big deal but I thought this was very
very interesting while they are down
here inside these tunnels in the cave
they're going to end up going to a
deeper and darker part of the cave and
they're actually going to discover some
cave paintings on the walls some of
these cave paintings will be the spirals
just like the spirals we have seen many
times before these paintings were
actually done by the children of the
forest and they could be very similar to
the weirwood circles that have been seen
before it's not quite the same in the
show as it is in the books
but the children have made these before
too
[Music]
Jon Snow and Daenerys realized these
cave paintings are very old and they've
been here long before the Targaryen Zoar
Starks have ever been around it says
that Daenerys thinks these paintings
date back to before there were even men
but John is going to show her another
cave painting and this one is very
interesting as well the picture John
shows her is of five small figures with
three larger one and it's the children
of the forest and the first men coming
together to fight a common enemy which
is the White Walkers then they see
another painting and there is another
group of figures but it says one of them
is clearly the night King painted on the
wall and John uses these paintings as an
example to show Daenerys that even
though they may have their differences
this proves that there has always been a
need for them to come together and fight
this enemy apparently it says that
Daenerys is going to believe John Ian
agree with him and she does agree to
help him but only if he bends the knee
now this spoiler kind of blew my mind
when I first read it the children of the
forest have always been known to live in
caves and secret tree towns and I've
always wondered where the children was
getting their obsidian from this appears
to show that the children of the forest
were actually getting their obsidian
from dragon stone - and they may have
even gotten the dragon glass they used
to create the night King from one of
these caves
[Music]
[Applause]
and I'm going to be honest with you if I
went into one of these caves and saw
cave paintings of little children of the
forest and those spirals and some White
Walkers and the night King I would be
creeped the [ __ ] out do any of you
actually think this has a deeper meaning
to it than just showing that people with
differences have had to come together
before in the past in order to defeat
their enemy
these weirwood circles and spirals keep
popping back up and are most likely
going to play some kind of a role in the
endgame we have seen these designs many
times before even back in season one
when med beheaded the man from the
Nights Watch if you look at the stone
formation around the stump the large
pieces of stone are actually in a circle
similar to how the ice blocks were in a
circular formation where the knight King
turned the baby into the white Walker
this kind of thing has always interested
me and made me very curious as to what
else this could actually mean these cave
paintings may not end up meaning much
more than what John said they proved but
they still intrigue me nonetheless and I
have a feeling we may see the children
of the forest once again I actually
don't think bran stark is going to stay
at Winterfell for the rest of his life
or at least for the rest of this series
I should say I know it seemed like the
rest of the children or the forest are
dead and they died in the cave when bran
Hodor and Meera had to escape but there
might actually be more of them at the AL
of phases where the first pact was made
brain may end up being led down there
now that he is the three-eyed Raven and
as we saw in the last episode bran
really doesn't fit in with regular
society anymore
he is so distant from everyone and has
really lost touch with most human
emotions and I feel like he's going to
need to leave Winterfell in season 8 and
if there are any more children of the
forest I think bran will have to find
them because in the books it is said
that the children of the forest can
speak with the dead they don't talk and
have language like humans do like they
did in the show so if that's the case
bran might actually have to end up being
able to do the same thing bran might
actually end up being one of the only
people who can communicate with the 19 I
think if there is anyone that is going
to be able to speak with the dead then
it has to be brand now that he is
arguably one of the most powerful people
in the show we already know that bran in
the night king can interact with each
other in the same vision we saw the my
team reach out
touch bran so I think once a brand
learns how to fully harness his powers
he might actually be able to do much
more than that
hell he might even learn how to get
inside the night Kings head
[Music]
but I don't want to go too far down in a
10-fold territory but I just have a
feeling we haven't seen the last of the
children or the forest there is still so
much more to learn obviously but comment
down below and let me know what you
think about the paintings in the cave do
you think that this is enough evidence
for Daenerys to trust John and no longer
ask him to bend the knee and curious to
see what all of you have to say about
this as always thanks for watching a
video I really do appreciate that the
channel has been growing tremendously
ever since the season started all the
support I've been getting has me at a
loss for words I never could have
imagined this many cool people would
actually want to come to my channel and
talk about Game of Thrones but I'm so
happy all of you actually have thanks
again and I also want to thank my
patreon supporters you continue to
support the channel and I love all of
you for that I hope you have a good day
I will see you down in the comment
section bye
[Music]